cercai di prendere il pezzettino fuori
dal finestrino
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è la prima volta per un
tema così importante ho deciso di
chiedere aiuto in realtà non solo una
persona ma un gruppo di persone un
sinodo di individui che come potete
vedere alle mie spalle appartengono
magari un canale che qualcuno di voi
seguirà non sono negli studios di casa
mia sono negli studios della valle
spaziale quindi senza bisogno di
aggiungere altro eccovi gli space
ballerino grande amico benissimo
carissimo tipo maggio del montaggio era
quello che ho capito però era molto
rocambolesco e questo ti ringrazio tanto
ciao scusa ciao
se non conoscete questo format è molto
semplice quello che facciamo e ascoltare
le messaggi legati a un tema in
particolare e li commentiamo la cosa
migliore è partire subito con i messaggi
che poi ci si scioglie e magari persone
che magari hanno un bel bagaglio di
esperienze potrai condividere con noi
ok va bene perché guardi guardi voi non
lo sapete ma cioè essere a un aneddoto
per ogni cosa e questo aneddoto
solitamente a che vedere con la pipa un
bell'equilibrio ottima sito all'altro mi
fa ridere che se ci si anto ti pulendo i
denti con la lingua che siamo cristiani
avanti se volete io per ora preferisco
pulire il palato apri la bocca come i
coccodrilli
ma di solito gli audio che ti arrivano
sono tosti ci dobbiamo aspettare
qualcosa di veramente scoppiettante che
talora dipende tanto dal tema la prima
volta si può spaziare è esatto diciamo
che si spazia in generale proprio a
livello fisico ma voglio capire quanta
responsabilità abbiamo noi 0 cosa dire e
fare quello che vogliamo non abbiamo
nessun limite
siamo un programma family friendly in
questa cosa vuol dire che tutto quello
che viene detto o viene mappato tagliato
abbiamo avuto tommaso zorzi ragazzi cioè
potete dire quello che vi pare
cesare no sono libero solo libero ciao
gubri il sondaggio prima volta faro
veloce perché appunto imbarazzante
primissima volta con il mio primo
fidanzato in auto al buio mentre il
tizio cercava della giusta vita di
entrata avendo più volte a un certo
punto si sposta quindi il telefono che
all'epoca non avevano applicazione
torcia decide display per fare luce con
quello lì ed esclamare l'antichità con
la noia 33 comprerà un minatore bull ma
è quello che mi pare strano senso la
torta poi sembra adesso c'è il gps
comunque più tranquillo mercato la roma
di nuova generazione più alla mia non e
sensore i bambini beep beep beep beep
più ti avvicini il parcheggio ci sono
anche certe mattine che hanno un
dispositivo opposta credo rileva vicino
alla doppia frequenza che quella il
cambio va bene grazie per l'amarezza
allora buongiorno sono roberto da centro
assistenza di amazon che il corriere ha
bisogno della sua assistenza per trovare
dove si trova questa chiamata può essere
scissa da per mo di tip addensamento
corriera ha chiuso la chiamata mi
dispiace che lui è molto vicino al punto
di carceri andiamo a cercarlo grazie e
buon lavoro a caccia del corriere ground
ciao guscio spire volevo raccontarti di
quella volta in cui eravamo in macchina
e presi dalla passione incominciamo a
fare cose ecco l'unico problema è stato
quando durante l'atto non so cosa mi
cose mi successe però è stata una pagina
perché può essere una brutta figura
naturalmente cerca di prendere i
pezzettini fuori dal finestrino
[Risate]
la campionessa sono posto così abbiamo
fatto il video a quei dieci secondi in
cui sei libici due prime volte in una è
il classico effetto seppia che voglio
bene ciao ciao ospite che dire beh nella
prima prima volta ormai un bel po di
anni fa posso solo dire che ricordo la
quantità de capocciate contavo sul muro
e il fatto di non riuscire a dirglielo
che con questione ma mi ricordo
solamente il dolore della casa è un
classico però fa impressione che non
glielo dicesse c'è chi apprezza
io conosco una ragazza per esempio che
si è fatta a spaccare il naso con
pacifica e musi phone hubble serio a
posto le piaceva proprio nella follia
l'argentino lei non voleva che le
spaccasse davvero andrenalina bullo
voleva che ma lei diceva continua la
entrato in moto e tutto quanto cioè ha
finito e l'hanno chiesto ma per le
olimpiadi di boxe non è stata una serata
un pochino così toccante
ciao ciao spiteri scusate se parlo piano
ma si è fatta una certa comunque volevo
raccontare un aneddoto un po particolare
praticamente avendo io un problema alla
spalla destra una postazione cronica che
quindi ogni tanto se faccio dei
movimenti un po inconsulti la spallina
mi scappa via mission loro una sera mi è
rapportato con questa relazione con
tavolo un po aggiunti finalmente al
momento di di consumare abbasso il
sedile è una volta sopra di lei mi
fuoriuscire la spalla proprio nel bel
mezzo del dell'atto
inutile dire che poi la serata preso una
piega un po imbarazzante perché non mi
si risollevò ovviamente più la
situazione sia per l'imbarazzo sia per
il fatto comunque ci misi un po di tempo
fare entrare la spalla dentro e il
testimone per lui e per le tante
disgrazie a un abbraccio che ti esce la
spalla la bara dei suoi prima già
trascinato che lui lo fa la mela spalle
paesi dimettermi ma io ne sta là dentro
posso spezzare una lancia a suo favore
per uno che è bravo a mettere di nuovo
la spalla dentro c'è deve essere un
cecchino
di sicuro la torcia non la usa come si
deve
se poi volete macinano no a quel sapore
di medico di anche questa per me
l'imprevisto che se mai sapere che cosa
succederà magari a lei è piaciuto poi
non credo che il silenzio che è stata la
spalla che ricevono i dialoghi che è un
cecchino mia prima volta euro oggi c'è
un ricattato il ragazzo che mi piaceva a
lui piacevano e per il mio e ha detto
che se lui avesse fatto l'amore con me
li lava il numero di quella ragazza è
così lui ha accettato e ho avuto la mia
prima volta è lui il numero della mia
amica che non se l'è filato di striscio
per me questa notte causare
lei ha vinto anche la strategia ma anche
un po come sta andando come l'ha esposta
io la prima volta che ho fatto sesso
scorretto e non mi
all
e stata una prima volta veramente di
anche perché poi la ragazza mi ha
lasciato il giorno dopo però ci ha
capito sarà ancora legato è un
palloncino decide di sei stato di fu una
dispersione di energia questo video sarà
molto difficile da montare e nel senso
perché sono tutte cose troppo hard core
dice che ho sbagliato io a dire che
thomas in questo difficile volevo
raccontarti della mia prima volta
io spezza una lancia a favore di tutte
quelle ragazze che un giorno hanno
deciso di rivelare amica si teneva molto
e sono arrivata ventiquattro anni senza
ovviamente avere nessun tipo di rapporto
perché avevo deciso che dovevo farlo con
la persona che amavo ma questa persona
da amare non arrivava e quindi a un
certo punto detto basta il primo ragazzo
che c'è stato sono stato anch'io e poi
non l'ho più visto è stato bellissimo
perfetto e poi da lì in poi sono
felicità perché a un certo punto basta
no vorrei se per la prima volta
dell'amica l'amica e tv vino e ronco
prof
roma tutti gli aspetti ragazzo che ha sì
un credo lo faccio più nessuno la
ragazza che non voleva far l'amore se
non con la persona che avrebbe amato per
cui girava bistecca questa similitudine
a bistecca si usa per un altro problema
sia altro che la bistecca quando la
bistecca al sangue che gira prima
ragazzi questo è vero la sua da venire
qua non dico niente
si chiamava grazie il tuo contributo
ciao ciao ospite per la prima volta è
stata un completo disastro
l'unica cosa che ricordo è l'aria che
faceva avanti e indietro e io guardavo
una finestra
non vedevo l'ora di tornare a casa è
stata meramente
orrenda che schifo questo vino viene
abbattuta dell'area che fa avanti e
indietro quel abbiate capito
stendiamo un velo pietoso sulle prime
volte che ne dici
[Musica]
valentina white non ho capito l'aria che
tira immaginati
no no problemi quei problemi diciamo di
salamini tunnel
grazie a due velocità mi va di dire
quello per dovresti dire cosa significa
salamine il tunnel mai detto saranno
riteneva che sarà mini tunnel salame del
tunnel cos'ha fatto che il tunnel no
allora
era giusto quello che ha detto ne sono
in esplicito mi piace racconta una prima
volta felice o quella della cacca non
l'ho vista turbata è uno di quegli
aneddoti e racconti gli animali la nonna
con queste mani il problema è che
rendono distrarmi ma i fastidi l'iter
fanno dovuto recitare tra mente rate
tagliatore comprendente colleganti è
stata particolare al mio segnale
scatenate l'inferno mandante delle
regioni e malia genera anche l'unico
dell'imperatore marco aurelio ennio film
perfetto che hai mai mangiato come del
sasso per rimorchiare se veramente mappa
dei pezzi da tenere di questo video in
panico è mai crampi e piedi pil mentre
lo stai facendo mai
ciao guglielmo ciao ospite la prima
volta che ho baciato il mio ragazzo è
stata particolare infatti dopo sei mesi
di tira e molla macelli in generale
finalmente ci baciamo si tratta più che
di un bacio di un limone durato cinque
minuti più o meno alla fine di questo
bacio epico lui mi guarda e mi dice ok
adesso vado a vomitare e ovviamente io
sono rimasta malissimo e verità è che
lui aveva mangiato una teglia di lasagne
e sostituito proprio male c'è realtà lui
dopo ha vomitato
comunque noi siamo ancora fidanzati
l'amore immagino tutto li perde che sta
per scoppiare esista che contiamo che
qualcuno dava a vedere il guinness del
primo a theprimate delle mimose ma non
lo so sarà il tipo 27 ore o giorni tipo
tre giorni che melo nei commenti
chiedero nei conventi fatecelo sapere
prima di un bacio assolutamente di
mangio la mentina non la teglia di
lasagne le lasagne l'energia per cinque
minuti di rimonta
allora la mia prima volta è stata non so
comica perché timori madre e mi sono
inventata le peggio
verdi voglio stare a casa da solo con me
stessa e il giorno dopo ritrovare un
pacco di profilattici sul tavolo con
scritto sotto lava i piatti e vabbè poi
sarò il tronco che ho camminato con un
bambino per due giorni e ho creduto che
è un dio che sofferenza sta roba ma che
ha così non scherziamo
niente vabbè bacio perché non è una
critica
allora casa l'hanno sentito modificata
questa luce che siamo noi la vera la
seconda è modificata è ancora più bello
cioè tipo pingu lava i piatti con i
preservativi
sì questa strana dice cioè se rimettere
il guardian vari questo e barocchi
buongiorno guglielmo buongiorno
soprattutto il rito
tutto bene allora la mia prima volta è
stata abbastanza strana perché sta
ragazza che lavorava in un teatro in
pratica per farla breve l'abbiamo fatto
troppo sul palco perché era vuoto
diciamo quel giorno 20 sono il palco e
dopo circa un'ora mezz'ora venivano gli
attori volti degli attori è scivolato
insomma ci siamo sui balconi ci potrebbe
essere sapone al cetriolo sono uguali
alla fine però c'è una scena in un film
famosa forse non si è comunque il
problema della durata e comune a tanti
italiani quindi italiani gli italiani
sono un po un popolo spirato a quel
punto di vista
[Risate]
questo ragazzi e dice di solito ti
dicono era in un problema se invece un
problema è un altro segno proprio la
carità ma anche da ingenui non pensare
che non lo sia ma io do un consiglio
fate negli altri parole continua infatti
a questa cosa non ha mai capito se dura
poco l'anti massimo adoperate lo rifà io
non ti prendi una siringa di cialis
avevo casa saga ciao guglielmo beh che
dire la mia prima volta è stata
imbarazzante sono stato quasi come che
si dice liquidato perché ero in camera
con questa ragazza
due anni piu piccoli di me sotto c'erano
dei miei amici mentre eravamo lì
nell'amplesso tutto quanto a una certa
parte la sigla di gossip girl e lei si
blocca di colpo che dice scusa mi devo
andare
c'è la mia serie tv preferita si è
rivestita il mio mollato il soggetto che
cattivo che ci rimani proprio male ap
hyper game of thrones per dinho scrubs
però si ragazzi dice tanto degli uomini
che sono delle merde con le ragazze ma
le ragazze quando ci si impegnano
messico per chi veramente distruggono
vite
vergognati ti devi vergognare ma no
ebbene qualcuno dica momento dove inizia
tutto mia madre mi chiamò e mi disse
telefono mi è successo qualcosa quando
sono dell'area casa era un po scioccata
però la vita basta così tutto quanto non
c'è un messaggio prima vietata per la
prima volta e che cos'è perché mi scappo
vado a cagare
ma offendono se no non ho sentito io ho
capito che questo è meglio non sentiva
ok adesso tutti se non altro nella
lanciata dal dire salire quindi bravo
noi lo stiamo nascondendo ma c'è a chi
piace c'è chi piace e molto
probabilmente sta tra noi 7 non è che
poi pensano che mi mangio ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video non
so se ringraziarvi grazie prima di
salutarvi volevo dirvi che questo
martedì è uscito un video nel loro
canale vi lascio il link qua sotto
se volete vedere io che il rischio di
sbracciare ogni due secondi andate sul
loro canale insomma lasciate un pollice
in su anno non lasciate pollice in su
perché se no devo masticare i suoi
anelli
detto ciò ringrazio di space valley
grazie come sempre vi dà un appuntamento
questa domenica con un'altra puntata di
cucina buttata
ciao